what's up you guys i just want to take a
moment and give you a background on
today's guest when i was 12 years old i
started working part-time at a company
that sold salt water fish and coral and
it was this job that really shaped the
entire way
looked at life work and business my old
boss chris who you're about to see here
was the one who gave me a chance and set
me up on the trajectory that would
eventually turn into real estate and now
today on youtube but i left that company
when i was 17 years old and since then
we have not seen or spoken with each
other in over 14 years
until now here's that conversation and
i'm excited to introduce the person
who's made all of this possible in the
first place so
enjoy welcome to the 57th ever
iced coffee hour my name is chris
turnier
and so far this podcast has made eight
thousand seven hundred and eighteen
dollars or seventy four cents
wow that was good i'm shocked that was
perfect i
met a loss of words that was the best
one i think we've had so far ever i
don't believe it
it's true you're lying you're lying jack
never lies
it's it's true i can see it in his face
he lies good
more importantly it's yeah it's an honor
to have you here an honor to have you
here
it really is i i am being honest when i
say this this is the episode that i have
been looking forward to for years like
before even the iced coffee hour before
youtube
being able to do something like this
i've been looking forward to this now
you obviously know based on the title
but you're my first boss
ever back when i was i think 12 or
13 years old no that's like i don't
think so i don't think it was quite i
think you're i think so
i don't know i think you're seventh
grade if you're lying i think jack is
lying
jack is lying yeah they're always a
bunch um yeah i mean i get i'm because
when i left for fiji it was
2007. and so where were you
in 2007. barely using i was barely
leaving the company in 2007.
right so but at that point you were you
regret you
graduated high school i think right and
then you flunked out
you flunked out of college because i was
like no
yeah and then and because of reefer
madness
yeah because of my because of my company
yeah so
and then so i mean we weren't robbing
cribs at that point but
so yeah i i don't know i mean i i'm
trying to remember i couldn't
at that point i'm not sure if you were
working for me for four years or five
years i'm not sure
yeah i think i was 12 or 13 when i
started working with you and for those
that are aware
you say reefer madness yes and people
are going to assume it's
reefer something else i'm thinking the
reefer is it not
no it is not it is not smoke it's a
reefer because we
are technically reefers yes so reefers
basically mean that you're keeping a
reef tank it's an aquarium with
corals and tropical fish and
um yeah it's a it's a crazy addictive
hobby
yeah that i've been doing for a long
long time so um and still just as
addicted to this day
right it's something so when i was 12
years old when i was i yeah i think it
was either 11
i was 11 years old i was 11 years old
and i
got bit by the saltwater aquarium bug
and my mom
was not was not about the salt water
tanks she thought it needed too much
maintenance but my dad was on board with
it
and so we ended up getting a saltwater
tank set up and at that time i would
spend
all of my time all my free time
basically after school on like
reefcentral.com which was basically it's
a forum
of other aquarium enthusiasts who would
come together and talk about their love
for like
keeping fish and coral and we would
share our like thoughts of
and about husbandry and like how to grow
this stuff and i would be getting home
from school
and basically from like 4 p.m to 9.
i was on reefcentral.com just like
posting and there were live people on
the other end that were getting back to
you no they're robots
yes kidding no you're mostly wrong the
good life
who do you think you're talking about
yeah they're crazy crazy
sort of question on it if you go online
on the forum who's on the other side
it's a
who would foreign be crazy a dick oh so
it's a human humans
it's a form it's imaginary thousands of
users
yes like imagine reddit yeah okay but
imagine
before reddit and communities like that
there were bulletin boards and forums
which would basically be a website that
you go to with like different i know
i've been on forums before okay
so that's what it was so there's humans
on the other end yes what forums do you
go on where there's not a human on the
other end
i'm just saying it just you know all
right get it clear so there are other
people on the other end
were you one of these other people you
use the forms
yes i was actually at one point i i did
a lot of because there was a lot of
questions about specific corals and how
to care for them and what this is and
what that is and where to put it in your
aquarium and so and so forth so i would
go on there
try to id stuff try to tell people what
their care was it was a lot of work but
yes
i used to do that a lot yeah so i was
really into this
and i would say maybe when i was like 13
years old
there was this guy his name was dave and
this sounds super sketchy like looking
back at this like if i had a kid i'd be
super sketched out
if the kid comes and say hey i want to
go over to this guy's house and see his
aquarium
how old is he i don't know in his 40s
and he wants to invite me over to his
house to look at his pictures and he's
pretty sketch
he's a great guy but he's really nice
guys super nice guy so
this guy dave and cerzero
dave and i had talked online for a
did he say he was 40 online or did you
know that when you met him
that's a robot it sounds ridiculous
so i was talking to this guy dave online
and he was on reef central
and he was posting what's called a frag
swap
and basically what this is i know it's i
know it sounds ridiculous what this was
is when when other aquarium hobbies
would get together they would
frag a piece of their core like they'd
basically chip off a piece of the coral
and they'd trade it with other people
and you could grow it
dave wanted to do a frag swap which is
basically
[Laughter]
he was the only one there at the frag
swap
yeah so he was doing this big backyard
frag swap
we're basically all the guys online
we're going to get
it sounds it sounds it's just laughing
over there
it's just a way to say i mean there's no
other way to explain it right anyway
it was called the backyard's frag swap
and
i'm sorry i'm sorry can you move my mic
or something i'm sorry
keep going a backyard frag swap and
people would get together and sell their
fish and coral and little pieces of it
and i was like 13 years old and i begged
my mom
i wanted to go to the frag swap so my
mom said yes we can go to the frag swamp
and we got there early by the way so she
could meet dave
and so she met dave dave was a really
nice guy
like over the top nice like the type
that he just
he just wanted to help a kid out and he
saw like how into fish and coral i was
so everything that day was was so much
fun i was able to meet a lot of it as
soon as we were
able to meet a lot of the people online
that i was talking to like on the forums
and i think it was a local forum right
it was los angeles
southern california southern california
yeah so it was called the southern
california reefers
yeah yes there's how the reefers come in
so i was able to meet all these people
that i talked to online and i don't
think any of them knew how old i was
because i just had my screen name online
i don't think i really was your screen
name
i'm not gonna say it's insane because
then people are going to be able to look
it up
say it i don't even remember ultimate
reefer
so embarrassed pineapple house
oh that's right yeah i remember yep
really i really like spongebob
i really like spider and so i figured
pineapple
i don't know okay so now you can look me
up on on reef central
but anyway so that was my screen and
people didn't know how
how old i was but anyway so i show up
there and
everyone has like a little name tag in
my pineapple house graham
and i'd show up and uh and basically
meet everybody and i was so excited to
be able to buy like pieces of
fish and coral and you had uh a friend
and employee andy who was basically sent
to this frank swap to represent the
business of reefer madness
reefer madness was one of the biggest
spawn one you were a big sponsor on
reefer madness
um
madness was a big sponsor of reef
central so you'd always see the banner
at the top for reefer madness
and andy was sent there to be a
representative of free for madness
so i met andy selling a few pieces of
fish
and i think it at that point i don't
think you sell pieces of fish
or sorry in this importantly say it
again if you do pieces of fish
they're you know it's more like sushi
that would be really expensive sushi
again like a blue tang like a little
nemo i can say that i don't know but
little pieces of that usually on the
rice yeah you can't frag
a fish okay thanks for clarifying okay
yeah i don't know it's been a while
since you've had a tank so
you might have forgotten so so andy was
selling pieces of coral there
and i think dave made the introduction
to andy and
i was like enamored that like someone
from reefer madness was there
and i think andy said that i could come
by the warehouse
and just check it out and i told my mom
like we could go after school we could
go to the warehouse i could take a look
at this
which warehouse do you i mean you'd
probably get that so it was at this
at the pacific aqua farms walt smith
smith it was by
uh lax and my mom said yes
so we connected with andy drove down to
reefer madness and you were there
and i remember the first time i was
there being like blown away
like this was a kid in a candy store
moment because
i had my my aquarium set up and going to
like the local fish store is one thing
but being able to go into a wholesaler
of like i don't know 10 20 30 000 square
feet
of fish and coral all in like huge light
it's just
long raceways you're right yep
watercolors hundreds of
fish thousands of corals and to see this
i was just like blown away that like
this exists
and everything you could ever want was
like was there and so
i was introduced to chris and i think i
was just so blown away at like looking
at everything and i knew
all the names of everything i studied
every name of every coral out there and
i could be like oh that was a
montipora capricorn so this is a
acropora nobilis and like just all these
names
and i think you offered me a position
where like if i wanted to come in after
school i could help out
what was going through your mind at that
point like i'm some kid
walking into your business just picking
out names and efficient coral
well the the funny thing is about about
people and
and well and the reefing hobby is that a
lot of folks they
they're into the they're into like the
mechanics of it they're into like the
plumbing they're into the lighting
whatever
but in this in your situation you knew a
lot at that age i mean i think you
you know you pretty much astounded me
to be able to name a lot of those corals
so
when i see i don't see it often even now
after doing this so many years there's
very few people that actually can pick
up and
identify those particular corals because
not only do you have to remember a
scientific name
but you also have to remember the common
name that was used
in the in the aquarium and the reefing
hobby yeah and there's
hundreds of thousands of names each
company i mean especially nowadays each
company has their own name some
some they use from from company to
company but a lot of them are unique to
the company
and so you knew i mean back in those
days it was a little bit different than
today because yeah
today you're fragging a lot but back
then especially for a reefer madness
reefer madness actually used
uh sorry imported corals from fiji from
tonga from the islands of fiji from the
islands of tonga
from bali from indonesia so on and so
forth and you're getting colonies
you're acclimating these colonies you're
photographing those colonies you're
selling those colonies
so you somehow i don't know why at that
age you would be
so into it you knew that and i'm like
game on
and yeah you know and i think i think at
that point we just said
yeah why don't we you know see if he can
do it part time
start helping out with you know whatever
and uh
i think it and five years later and you
flunk out of school yeah
i don't know if that was the best
decision but you know it's
it's good so back then was it because
you wanted the help
or was it because you just like the
enthusiasm
for me it's always about enthusiasm okay
if you have if i'm gonna hire somebody i
have to have that enthusiasm it's
it's hard to you can't force
you you can't force that the the desire
to to learn
that particular stuff like for me an
example you know from
you know some of the finance stuff you
that you you know you do a lot of that
stuff is
you know i try to remember but yeah
naming a coral you know figuring out
that speci
the species of fish boom it's like pam's
right in there yeah
so that's that's kind of the thing that
you know that's the that's
if i see it i i you know i'd like to be
able to what
kind of cheesy term but nurture it and
that's because it it helps us in the
long run for sure
right did my age concern you about being
like i
i i was probably 12 or 13. i'm sure i
sure did at the time i can't really
remember i mean that's a long time ago
right but um you know that's what 2003
yeah 2003 so that's a long time ago and
that was before we even moved to our
you know the second location um
so yeah no i'm i'm i'm sure that was the
main thing it's just the enthusiasm
that that makes up for you know 90 of it
for sure
i was so excited too it was every
tuesday and thursday
i get picked up from school and either
my mom or my dad would drive me over
to the where dad had the ford explorer
yep i remember the red
i think it was red he had a green one i
had a green one and then the red was
later that was yeah right
all right so i didn't remember something
yeah yeah the green ford explorer
would drop me off and then i forget my
mom would go and like read a book
sometimes which i hated i hated that she
would like be around all i just wanted
to go and leave
and then let me do my thing but
sometimes she'd stick around and like
read a book which
i just i didn't like that but uh but my
dad would just drop me off
and uh then come and pick me up
sometimes like nine or ten o'clock at
night
and i was i didn't even want to leave
and there were several times too where i
would be there until probably 11 p.m or
midnight you would leave usually around
9.
13 years old yes i was working i loved
it
so we would have these shipments come in
from i believe it was fiji
and maybe thompson or two yep that was
amazing
thursdays those are the main suppliers
right in particular yep they would come
in at like 4 p.m
i would help unpackage some of these the
the the coral
uh and then photograph it and sometimes
like on on thursday i was photographing
tuesday's coral
and then on the tuesday it was
photographing thursdays because we had
to give it enough time to adjust and
make sure it was okay
um and yeah and i just was obsessed with
photographing
as many different corals as i could
because we would get boxes and boxes it
would probably be sometimes 100
you know 150 corals in a shipment right
so and you're unboxing them you've got
these big boxes i mean
we call them coffin boxes because
they're they're huge
yeah they're they're massive and each
box would probably hold
you know between um eight to
16 corals i'd say for an example and
then we'd be unpacking those
and then you have to put them in a
certain location in those tanks with a
good amount of flow going by them
you let them what's called polyp out and
polyps are the little they have little
like discs coming out all the sides of
the branches of the corals
and those have to open up before you can
photograph them so you got to give them
that amount of time to be able to open
and that was
yeah that was your that was your job
yeah would you stay until the work is
done
or would you finish up the work and kind
of just hang around and look at the
coral and stuff
uh both i i would hate to ever leave a
job when finished
um but if i finished early i wouldn't
tell my parents to pick me up
because i would be there i loved just
being able to look because i could keep
the lights on and and i don't
i don't know if that was responsible
back then like because i i was the only
one in the warehouse
like 13 maybe 14 years old and i had the
code
to the front and i think i had a key or
something like that but i would be the
one at like 10 or 11 p.m
remember you tell me do the code and
then i'd have to lock the door when i
left
and i loved it i loved having the whole
place to myself
uh we had the radio going and i could
control the lights which i thought was
the coolest like i could keep the lights
on above the coral
and yeah i would just i would ideally
just keep going
until i was finished but sometimes
there's too much and by like 11 pm my
mom or dad would say no this is enough
we got to stop but
i would just keep going but
yeah and i think we're responsible to
get those those uploads done for me so
that was kind of
a pretty important job who was doing the
job before graham
me you were yeah most part yeah
yeah um yeah i mean that was my
responsibility i mean the main thing was
is always reaching your deadlines for
those but to making sure that those
products because
the cool thing is and it's unusual i
think even today is having
what you what you see is what you get
products
work so i you were one of the first to
do that by the way yes
and that actually that was before reefer
madness that was a company that i
that i um i was one of the managers for
a long time
prior to that called flying fish express
and that was
oh gosh that was 90. that started
97. and we we were the first one
at that point to do the what you see is
what you get corals
the whole industry the whole hobby
progressed with the development
of these halide bulbs
now they use leds but back then like
what you have on your reef tank
now um back then they were halide bulbs
and
the the whole industry kind of started
to make a move to more of a blue light
because before they were using like
yellow
65k look like sunlight every all the
corals look brown and green and they
didn't look very good
but we started making this move toward
um this blue lighting
and it just made the corals pop it
brought out this phosphorescence
so that was the whole goal is to produce
these what you see is what you get
corals
and that was what you're you know that's
your job taking those corals
photographing them making sure that the
color was true using photoshop
um and an slr camera at that point
actually i think we were using your
camera was that sony
yep that thing was sony cyber shots it
was a killer
amazing camera back in the day yeah it
was it was a sony cyber shot because we
used
something it was like it wasn't quite as
good but then you brought your
you brought your sony in there this huge
huge barrel and had a carol's uh
sorry um carl zeiss lens and that thing
and
even today i mean those carl's ice lens
are yeah yeah they're really good lenses
um so yeah so back in the day that was
uh
that that was a yeah i'd still consider
that a decent camera to this day which i
think so too it was able to get really
good macro shots
which back then by the way uh i think
this was like a seven
megapixel camera what are they at now
how many megapixels do they have now
these cameras right here no like 22 but
how much do they cost
over two grand all right so i found it
okay so this is it
sony cybershot f707
five it's five uh megapixels
and this is the camera yeah i think oh
wow
that was sweet yeah it was back then 99
bucks you got it yeah 100 bucks
yeah back then if you want to be a
burgeoning reefer and take some photos
there you go get up
get one of those you'd actually be you
could still get some decent yeah
shots this was like the the camera of
camera right now an iphone would
probably do like 10 times better
but this was the camera to get back in
2003.
my ipod touch like fourth generation was
like five or seven megapixels
that's funny yeah but back to reefer
madness the other thing too that was
unique was that
you were one of the first to really go
online with
with fish and coral and sell uh
individual pieces in the what you see is
what you get category what what sparked
that besides
the flying fish express what made you
want to go off on your own from that
well i was also one of the i was the
very first and i get
cursed at because of it but to actually
name
attempt to name corals down to a
scientific level and actually give
them specific names because before
i came around this it was green acropora
for example
green staghorn or blue stag horn or
you know whatever purple you know
whatever and so
i took it to the next to make it a
little bit more personable
because reefers as we call them
are very um they're very they're
addicted
they love it so the more personable you
can
make the coral the more you can
assimilate with
something in real life i think it also
does well to tweak their interest into
um you know following you know kind of
like a
breed of dogs or breed of cats um it
it does well to try to get their
excitement growing even more
um so i think that was part of it um but
just the technology
has come along you know came at that
point as even was coming further
and then the like i mentioned about the
blue lights the 20k
bulbs or the 15k bulbs so on and so
forth they
that also brought out a lot of corals
the colors that you didn't see
previously right when did you come up
with the first name
like really naming the corals that was
actually flying fish express with those
clamps
okay we started we sure but we went even
further
we started you know doing names that
were get
even more off the wall um you know i
don't know if i can say this but i mean
one that always sticks out to me like
super girl's nipple
um i mean just we had some crazy you
know that wasn't natural
that was the name of one of the corals
because it was it was blue and green
i did of course um it was blue and green
and had all these like
projections it was all the projections
and when you would cut one and when
you'd frag one off it would be you know
pointed so on and so forth so
and then somebody would glue that to
their rock to their live rock to their
structure and their reef tank
um and yeah so you know i had all sorts
of those
well i did some uh madness.us
yep i did some stocking watch the the uh
speech you you get you gave uh oh which
one yeah which one
i don't know it was one of them but but
this is the screenshot
uh and we'll we'll put this up on the
screen for everyone to share but you
know what i want you to
oh yeah yeah there it is but i've got
much better images
okay i just did a screenshot okay oh
yeah so
see some of those are nuts i gotta find
one
so before we go into some of the names
your reasoning behind this
these names was that it just gave a more
personal touch yes
the quarrel yeah it just made him funny
yeah it made it funny it made it
it made it i mean it made it to the
point where just like click bait
um it i think a lot of people would
reefers would look
forward to coming to that page because
they would
see they would see these crazy these
off-the-wall names
that whether they purchased the coral or
not um
it made it it made it that much more
interesting we came up with some really
wild nibs it was it was
the more it didn't make sense the better
time to sell your kids because
because we have this outrageous
something something and something
yeah we we had some like your wife is
going to leave you after you buy this
like
crazy corn just like we had nothing the
whole community just like
are they the people are it made no sense
but
a lot of people would purposely come to
the website and the website had it
it had a consistent schedule of uh
refreshing so you knew i think at like a
certain time on like
a thursday morning at 9 00 a.m the
website would refresh and everyone would
come to the website
and they would either see the cool
colonies that came in or they would read
the names
for fun because the names were all so
just
they made no sense at all but they were
funny
it was it was different there was
nothing really out there yeah there's
nothing i mean still i mean
to this day i don't know how much yeah
how much does it take to start the
business
let's talk about some of the financials
well let's see the
the website back then i think was
probably it was right around between 50
and 20k to build
because of how much it was a lot we had
this um this guy named skip who actually
did
um the a lot of the web development yeah
he basically did the web development i
never really liked it
i never liked skip skip the skip was
always very short with me what qualms
did you have with skip what did he do to
you
he would he just was never friendly he
was tim at least to me he was never like
a
like an overly he wasn't a warm guy
i like skip skip was cool to me i mean
okay i mean maybe because i was the
owner but
yeah but whatever but yeah you know
maybe you're just you know
you were kind of snotty to him maybe
maybe maybe i had the attitude
but maybe it was at the end of the day
and he didn't want to deal you know
potentially yeah
so yeah um but yeah he built this and he
built this guy this monty or
our mascot and he he did this i mean
three-dimensional artwork for it which
was pretty cool back in the even the day
he took this
these colonies of zoanthids which are
these singular polyps that have all
these crazy colors and he stretched it
out of a
three-dimensional stretch it around a
three-dimensional frame
and he built that and he built the
structure of the website and um
um and then we had to pay rent to
pacific hawk farms
so because we were renting we actually
rented
uh raceway space so this from these
raceways these long raceways that we we
talked about earlier
um and we paid rent for that and for an
office where we did our
our photography work um and then our
advertising
and what's that do you remember how much
the rent would be i don't i don't
remember
okay i don't remember the thousands it
was probably around there
okay it was probably around there um
because i do remember that when we did
move
to our own location cup you know um
several years a couple years later
that it was um i remember the rent was
quite a bit higher i mean and it was
it was more of a struggle for sure
because you know the electricity
and for you know because we were running
these massive thousand watt bulbs over
our systems
um the electricity went much up much
higher so
the rent and the electricity and you
know and so on and so forth
so the initial cost were was the website
um and the website really didn't change
a whole lot over those time over those
years i think um
but i think we were using dreamweaver
for the structure of the website
but it wasn't a database driven site
either um
so because back in those days so it was
it was really just
um people emailing us the number of the
particular coral
and then we would and then my lovely
wife would actually go in and with their
customer amazing customer service
would mark those particular so and then
you know the people would pay for it
really wait wait wait so was there not a
checkout
no not back to those days what wait so
wait how did this
work it was like basically first come
first serve a lot of it
via email so you would have to email yes
i think it was like christine
reefermadness.us
with the sku that you wanted yes in the
beginning in the very beginning wow
the very beginning and then i think we
progressed toward a you know toward a
shopping cart as it worked that was one
of the main pushes
but you'll see the idea at the very
beginning yeah it was it was uh
it was not a shopping cart it was not
database driven where did you get the
money
to start it up because 15 20 grand for a
website back then that's
plus the overhead so it's like 20 volt
yeah
and you know that we we kind of worked
together and made that happen
so yeah wow so it was uh it was a chunk
of change but
they were doing um you know importing
from from fiji
and then um sorry exporting from fiji
and running pacific
and and and supplying pacific aqua farms
yeah some of those it just kind of
progressed and and worked and i might be
off on that 15 20 grand but i'm pretty
sure it was pretty close because
how much artwork and how much time i
mean that guy skipped
he skipped worked on it for uh for for
quite a few months before it was really
for before it was ready
what was that like running your own
business like that because it taking it
from
the small little raceway to then having
your own shop having
i think it was two employees plus myself
it was andy and mirna
and he was there no yeah and i was there
and then yep grant
um i don't know it was all natural i
don't it was a natural trend
you know um and then christine of course
yeah um it was just
it was it was just a natural um
move to you know to to running that just
to growth in general i don't
i don't know if it was all conscious or
not i think it was just something that
had to be done i do remember
you know uh working 36 hours straight
one time
and almost i almost actually fell off
the top of of a catwalk where we
were the raceways i was so tired it was
like the 35th hour or something trying
to get the
trying to we had a deadline to try and
get this this warehouse going because we
were
i think shut down for a couple weeks
because we couldn't we didn't have any
corals we were moved out of pacific farm
off
pacific aqua farms and we were
trying to get this this warehouse up and
running
and i just remember working 36 hours on
top of this catwalk
trying to set up these lights and
everything started getting you know
wonky and
and i like had to catch myself on on one
of the
on one of the bars otherwise i would
have like gone head first like
15 feet down under the into onto the top
of the raceway
that probably would have been very
pretty but luckily you know we
we made it through and we got those
systems running and we got salt water
from we had a big saltwater bin
we got we actually brought water up
straight from scripps
ucsd they had a they had a basically um
there was a company that was uh getting
water from kind of a deep
deep off of san diego county and it was
trucking it up to us and
and and that's what we use for our for
our systems and
yeah it was just a it was just a it was
a cool it was a cool
time it was it was hard yeah i remember
how how much you were working
like all the time late at night you were
constantly even
weekends saturday sundays you were
working on stop yep yeah
and i still do the same time
yeah it's not much change so i was i'm a
little confused so you were
what the manager of reefer madness
no i was no i was owner i was okay i was
part i was part owner
so yeah i basically ran it yeah you're
part owner of reefer madness
yes got it what was the day-to-day
business like
because i knew i remember being like i
i think i was 15 when you moved in it
was 2005 and seeing some of these orders
come in for
a thousand dollars or like fifteen
hundred dollars and in my mind
to me that was all profit like i didn't
get the concept of like you have
overhead you have expenses like
everyone working there is getting paid
it's electricity
so i would think wow like i thought back
then like you might
you yeah i'd see these were like six
thousand dollars and i'd be like
six thousand dollars yeah like 25 orders
a day
right yeah we had good business but
yeah no because you have mortality so
because this is
these are living corals and
unfortunately sometimes those corals
don't you know don't make it um they
don't survive the shipping
they have some issue that comes in later
um
they yeah so it didn't
always do well you have overhead i mean
the the place to the
the sorry the cost of of heating the
place or cooling the place
the cost of fedex the cost of
advertising the cost
i mean it's just one thing after another
um it was not
whole yeah not incredibly uh
profitable for selling colonies on the
other hand selling fragments
and once you get a fragment you start
something that can become once you get a
self-sustain you become a gardener yeah
um
then it becomes a bit more profitable
let's talk a little bit
more about graham graham's relationship
with you as his boss okay okay that
really excites me
you know let's talk about it so
obviously
the relationship between a boss and it's
him and his employees
is very unique because like you know you
have one person giving orders one person
receiving orders
was there ever any flack between
graham and you was there ever anything
that you told
graham to do that didn't sit very well
with you graham
i'm trying to think if if he ever gave
me any kind of
flock
i don't remember he was he was pretty
damn good he because
see the problem we're trying to we're
trying maybe graham remembers some
but i mean i i'm pretty i was pretty
easy guy to work for
for the most part i just wanted my
deadline if if you reach your deadline
and you
you know you did a good job i think you
got a little whiny sometimes when i
asked you to re-edit
photos sometimes you got kind of whiny
about it
i mean he was making like at the end i
think he was making like a buck of coral
so if we're doing like 150 or 200 or 300
corals a week
that's for for a you know 15 16 year old
he's making good that was bad back then
that was bank i mean you think about it
you can do
i don't know how many corals you were
processing an hour i tried photoshop
oh yeah 100 corals was my minimum if i
was going in per hour
no no no no no no per hour no per hour i
think it was anywhere from 15 to 30
depending on what it was
and how quickly it could turn them out
like sometimes the bigger colonies took
longer because
it was difficult to photoshop and get it
accurate but like sometimes the smaller
things
just knock him out knock him out knock
him out knock him out um
so yeah he would definitely get whiny
sometimes when i would ask to go back
and re-edit some of those because i mean
it was a lot of work but you know i had
you know i had an expectation of what
stuff had to look like even to this day
um i do the same thing um very similar
to it and i
you know i will say okay i got to get
you know this has to look like this and
that's
because in my brain i know what the
coral looks like yes and it has to look
that way otherwise it it's
because the problem is if you produce a
coral that
um that isn't quite right
uh the issue is is that if the color's
off or it's too bright or too saturated
as
as as this industry believes um
that a lot of these corals just don't
look the way they they do in real life
um you have to be able to tone back you
have to
increase you have to pull it back you
got to crop it right you got to have the
right
it has to be clear it has to be concise
it has to be
you know it has to look right so you're
saying some sellers would turn up the
saturation
of the photos to make it seem like the
coral was more
colorful than it actually is because in
coral you want it to be very colorful
and vibrant
right but not overly so because if you
do it overly
so then you've got it's basically a
false representation yeah
of a particular you know the particular
coral so you got to make sure
and you see these astronomical prices
sometimes for a coral that one a
customer receives it
it doesn't look quite right like that so
back in the day
and colonies actually back when we were
doing it
um like that was it was actually even
more difficult
um because obviously the technology
wasn't quite the same
but the um but it was it was very easy
to get carried away
yep um for some of these corals because
they're coming from straight from the
islands only a couple days here and
you know in a captive environment coming
from the ocean
they get you know they're basically
collected by you've got
in fiji for example it was it was this
ex massive expanse of
3 000 square miles that you could
collect from
and these divers were going out to
specific dive spots
every day collecting these specific
corals and it basically equated to a
super i mean they did a study they do
studies on it every couple years
and you it's like a forestry forest so
you can have up to three percent of a
forest
and it's sustainable so they found with
the studies that they were doing that
that the collection in fiji um was
point zero zero zero one percent or
something
um is crazy sustainable uh so you're
going out there with a hammer and a
chisel and you're finding a specific
coral and you're you're
you're clipping it off right there at
the be right there at the base of the
coral where it's growing into the reef
you you knock that out you pop it off
the rock and then you
um you place it up on the boat you know
i'm sorry you get a big collection of it
you place those corals up on the boat
then those are
transferred to the main warehouse they
they're acclimated for a couple days or
so
then they are bagged up shipped out all
the way to the united states or wherever
they were going it's a lot of traveling
a lot of travel yep so the shipping cost
back then was
in these big boxes like we talked about
earlier um
that that was that was you know part of
it and then you you have to take those
corals
the way that they looked in the ocean is
one thing
but then once they're tr once they
travel and they ship they lose some of
that luster
and they're one of the reasons why we
had such large lights
the twenty thousand thousand watt bulbs
on our systems was to try and bring that
color out
and with those thousand watt bulbs you
could do it reasonably quickly
but the same thing you had to make sure
that you didn't over saturate those to
make it look like it you're
misrepresenting the coral and then you
know make sure and then it sells like
that and the customer gets it and you
complain because
customer service in this particular was
very very important so
i remember a few things i don't ever
remember getting any flack from you
or andy um not that i can remember maybe
there was something i did wrong or i
messed up something
i think maybe the worst i've ever done
is probably
i've shipped the wrong coral that
probably happened at some point that's
the only thing i could think of like
like an honest because
sometimes they look very similar and
sometimes i will have picked a piece
oh and you know what we would do to make
sure uh because everyone was held
responsible for what they did
we would put our i think it was we used
to put our initials or our like
you know a or g on each order so we
could always look back and be like
this order came in it was damaged or
this wasn't correct who backed this
order it'd be like oh there's a g
granted and i think maybe once or twice
i had shipped
the wrong coral by mistake they look
kind of similar sometimes if they close
up
it's almost impossible to tell what's
what so i'm sure i probably did that at
some point
but i would say i learned quite a few
things um from watching how you worked
uh the first one was customer service
and the customer service i remember
it was so important for you to make sure
the customer's always right
and i remember even we had a few like
trouble customers weren't always the
easiest
but you would always give them the
benefit of the doubt even if you knew
like
they were wrong they were complaining
they just want to be difficult
you would always make it right even if
it cost you money um
and i remember quite a few times too if
there was like a good customer
or uh uh or someone who's brand new
throw them in something for free
and i think the cost of that to you was
very little
thrown an extra piece of coral that
maybe had broken off but then started
growing again
throw that in the order always give more
than what they pay for
every single time always make sure the
order is better than what they would
expect that way
when they get it they're going to go
online be like wow i ordered this from
reefer madness and i got
an extra piece of coral that they threw
in for free
like stuff like that i think the
overhead was very little but
they would order again because of that
um
yeah because the customer servicing was
was really
i think the biggest thing for me and
that's the thing i've carried on this
entire time is always giving
uh the customer more than what they
would expect even on youtube
um just making free videos they'll
always get more
than what i received back so that was
really important for me
graham told me that so i noticed one
thing that's that's really interesting
with graham is that he has like a
no no questions asked refund policy yeah
on his teachable on like his courses
real estate yeah link down below yeah um
so like he has like a youtube creator
academy which teaches like strategies to
grow youtube channel and stuff like that
and people will ask for a refund maybe
with some really like
weird justification right and graham
will always offer them a refund within
the first wizard like three weeks four
weeks yeah no questions asked
sure let me refund you immediately and
he said he learned that principle
that was you yeah even before we had
even talked about this
it was it was from you doing that that i
was like makes sense
and we get people by the way we used to
do 30 days but we would notice the
people
on the 30th day on like the 23rd hour
hour you know 23rd hour and 30 minutes
in where it's like a 30 minute window
okay i got it it wasn't what i expected
you said
that we could get a refund so i want my
refund
and you go and look at the progress
they've watched the whole thing
and on that like it's not a coin they
just want it back yeah
and then unfortunately for us is that
like once that 30th day passes
the payment processor doesn't allow you
to issue a refund yeah they cancel you
out
and you don't have to do it out of your
own paypal exactly and oh yeah and they
they charge you fees on top of that yeah
so then i have to pay out of pocket and
eat the cost of the fees
and for them they're like well
technically you said within 30 days and
i'm
five minutes away from the 30 days we do
it anyway
and my reasoning was that if you get one
unhappy person they'll go online
and say he didn't give me a refund it
wasn't what i
expected and if that causes 10 fewer
people out there to want to give it a
shot because of one bad review
it's not worth it so i got that from you
because you didn't want a single bad
review you
especially on reef central such a tight
community that if one person says i got
something from reefer madness
it came in not as not as advertised they
wouldn't give me a refund they weren't
willing to work with me they're terrible
everyone else will be like wow i should
stay away but that was that was from you
yeah i always my thought was always that
if the publicity
is good but and bad publicity
you know can take you so only so far
yeah the good
publicity is that if you have something
if you develop this if you nurture it
and people will actually come back and
protect you
yeah your the community will actually
come back
online you know facebook instagram
what if you start getting some bad
publicity you will get somebody that
will say
hey they actually made it right for me
yeah and that
is everything yeah that is ever
absolutely everything
so i always uh and and i never had much
business
you know um education per se i'm i'm a
fisheries biologist by by schooling i
mean i got my fisheries degree
so this is all self-taught and it's all
just common sense to me in that sense is
that i
always thought that i needed to make
sure that the customer
as i said as you've heard through ages
customers always right and they are
right and now to an extent if you can
fight it
and fight a good fight then yes but for
that for the most part you're like
yep all right let's let's let's let's
move on we got to we got to keep moving
we can't
dwell on the past because you've seen
sometimes where they just
battle they just battle they go at it
you see the you know
you see the the customer and then you
see the response and you see the
customer again and it just gets
nasty and is that what you want because
what do you what do people remember do
they remember the good or they remember
the bad
yeah and almost always most repair most
people remember
the bad yeah especially if it goes on
and on that's very true but that's one
of the reasons too why
if if you look up any reviews for for
uh the program there's not a single bad
review
and very few people could ever say that
about anything they sell online you got
to have a bad review
uh and it looks like artificially too
good because there's not a single person
who says that i got this didn't like it
i asked for a refund he didn't give it
back to me and if anyone is honestly
upset
they're given a refund and they they get
to keep it for free so
i don't i don't think there's a single
bad review out there in
uh two and a half years not one person
has ever
said that they've been disappointed what
other
really important business principles did
you learn from chris yeah
honesty so i remember i hated doing this
you made me do this
if so sometimes these corals would come
in and they would get brown like they'd
come in like blue or purple and just
if they'd been sitting for like five to
seven days they would kind of turn
brownish they didn't look the same as
they were online
and you would have me call up to the
customers and tell them
that the coral they ordered doesn't look
like it does online anymore
i hate it because i felt bad i'm like
they're gonna get angry at me
if i tell them that their order that was
about to be shipped out today
doesn't look like that and if they want
something else instead
and i i got so nervous getting on the
phone
and uh like this is before like you
could just text
somebody i prefer just like to send a
text but
their phone number would be on the order
and it would be up to me in like one of
these big handheld phones
press talk dial on the number hi
this is john hey this is graham with
reefer madness how's it go
hey yeah and talking to the like i was
so scared
that's funny too because i bet like
you'd be like hi this is graham for
reefer madness
like who's running this operation
yeah hello yeah i don't know but
uh but everyone was really and they
really appreciated the phone call like
no one was upset ever some people would
be like oh man
that sucks uh what else you have and and
sometimes it would be
you know back and forth with you know
taking a picture of something else and
sending it
or giving a store credit if they wanted
to get something else but
everyone was happy that that you were
really honest
even if it wasn't that big of a deal and
there's a few times where i've said like
i don't even notice a difference like
it's like 95 percent the same thing and
chris was saying you still got to call
him because if he gets in they're not
100 happy with it
it's gonna look bad on us and so
sometimes you're overly cautious like
hey
coral doesn't look to say if you want a
discount on this we could we could do
that we could give you a store credit
you could still ship it you don't have
to get it
we could throw in some stuff for free to
make up for it but there's always
something where
they got more than expected even if even
if they didn't get the perfect order
yep so true to me it just gave me the
confidence of just like being able to
work around like adults
and be in that environment that i felt
like really set me apart
because once i started working i hated
school
like i was never a fan of school to
begin with but once i saw that like oh
wow i could i could
do something i really enjoyed doing and
in the beginning it was i was working
for free
and getting paid in fish and coral and
i'd like save up for like a sunburst
anthias and be like okay if i've worked
this
this week i could get a sunburst anthias
at the very end of it um
but once i started doing that and then
like making money
then i was like what's the point of
school and i remember i'd be sitting in
class this was this is because of you
i would sit in class and think this is
the biggest waste of time
in this hour if i photoshopped 20 pieces
i would get paid 20 and the opera and
like before i knew about
opportunity cost it was like i could be
making 20 i'm 20
poorer now because i'm sitting in a
class not doing something with my time
i'm
wasting my time and it was after that
that school was just
i hated it did not see the point didn't
want to do anything
other than just work so you're saying
chris is the reason
you you flunked out of high school 100
yeah
uh because once i got my driver's
license that's when it all went downhill
uh because before i was relying on
my mom or dad to drive me so they could
kind of control how much i worked
and my mom like mondays i couldn't go on
like certain days it was
it was uh tuesday thursday and sometimes
fridays um so they could control like
how often i was going there but once i
got my driver's license
i would go not not every day after
school i would say probably three
days a week after school i would just
drive down to torrance
and just work and i i don't know if you
knew this
but my senior i think it was my senior
year so i was i was 17 so this would
have been kind of the tail end of it
i made up a condition and i i found a
fake
doctor's letterhead on google printed it
out
and i and i and i i typed this out on a
letterhead
and i just did a fake signature that
said this is so stupid
i had a condition of like rare condition
of sleep apnea
that prevented me shut up you never you
didn't tell me this yeah
that prevented me from getting a full
night of sleep and i did well i did that
so that i could skip the first few
classes
because i didn't because it's like
working so late
i don't know if i was working late i
just didn't want to show up or i didn't
want to go
yeah okay um but yeah so i said i had a
sleep apnea
they believed it i don't know
they believe that so i skipped all my
morning classes
a very good example here for the younger
generation most
our demographics are probably or mostly
they so they say 18 to 35 so they're
probably out there
they're already there or getting close
to that point getting close they're
gonna write i don't know if that would
work right i don't know if that would
work now
no uh so i would basically skip all my
morning classes so that that was good
and then i made it a weird goal i made
it a goal of mine to miss
one day of school every single week
and so i wouldn't be about yeah and i
would wear a goal yeah that was the goal
one day and they did it how would you
miss so i would call up pretending to be
my mom
and i did a good imitation of my mom did
have you heard this
i don't know if you ever did it see if i
could do it without laughing
hi this is stefan i'm so sorry my son
graham isn't feeling well this morning
his condition of sleep apnea it's not
he's not feeling well so
i'm laughing right now but yeah i could
imitate it and i'm doing a bad job
because
that's good that's really good
and i forget what what her name her name
was like tracy at the at the front desk
and she'd be like oh we're so sorry you
know no problem we'll see him tomorrow
and i would just and i don't think my
parents knew this but i would just
often work for madness what did they
think when they saw your report cards
and stuff like that
my parents what did you think of graham
skipping all this school
chris wasn't there during it was andy
and he was there
and he was a bro and he was just like i
think even once he called in
for me how old is he how old was he at
the time
late 30s probably at that time yeah
mid-thirties like this
it's somewhere in there i think he's
pretty pretty close up maybe a little
bit older than i am yeah you're about
the same i don't know
yeah i can't remember andy called in
once or twice for me
or i think i gave his number as like the
doctor if they needed to verify and i
didn't know this
i don't think he did but i would work
during the day because i was afraid if
he if you
knew this i was working at home yes
right i was working at my
at my house i was doing the customer
service answering all the phone calls
doing all and doing some of the updates
i would name the corals you would edit
them yeah i would name them i would get
them up on the site on the website
so i think a lot of the days that um you
know that i was
i wasn't up at that you know at the uh
at the warehouse
um yeah you must have been uh i was
there you were you were there
when you yeah but it shouldn't shouldn't
have been
no i was there andy was yeah i have to
ask about that at some point yeah ask
andy about that but i think you only
came in was it twice a week i think it
was tuesdays and fridays
i came in when the when the shipments
since tuesday thursday yeah so i could
see the corals right when they
right when they're bagged and so i could
so i can know that whether a coral
you know how it would look yeah needed
to look for the website but yeah my
great suffered because i had
zero motivation to do any work at all
like to me school was just a waste of
time but wouldn't your parents encourage
you to get good grades
i think they they gave they gave up and
i think
uh well if andy's going to that point
like
um yeah i don't know i mean
my dad was disappointed but he was my
dad's very easy going
and my mom was was upset
but i was [ __ ] you just didn't care i
just didn't care
i really didn't care and i was upfront
with my teachers
with a few of them that i was just like
hey look i just don't get it
because they would ask me like is
something good they would think
something's going on at home
because i'm missing missing all of these
days of constantly like sick
um i was honest with them like i just i
don't get it
i i just don't have any interest in
learning you went up to the teacher
and they're like why are you like not
showing up to school you just yeah i
just don't
get it why do i have to show this yeah
trying to negotiate with the teachers
there was yeah
uh well i went to this this school that
was a little bit more alternative
no no smash was elementary school so i
was on
a scholarship at new rhodes high school
how did you get a scholarship
i've applied yeah
well not a scholarship that maybe what
is it financial financial aid
oh like a grant or something like a
financial aid it was financial aid they
they had a percentage of students in
there that couldn't
whose parents could not afford the
tuition that
uh were admitted and they only admitted
a few a year
and i just happened to be one of them
chris what did you think
about graham flunking out of high school
did you have any opinion on that you
knew my grades were bad
yeah i knew they were bad um
it's a little fuzzy at that point i
think we were getting ready to move to
fiji so
i think part of that was a little bit a
little bit fuzzy
um for my recollection but you know
i don't know you at that point you know
who knows
you know we we didn't know where you
were going to go for that point but
because i was whining you know reefer
madness was kind of
making a different transition um
so yeah it's it's hard to say i don't i
don't really
recollect too much but i'm sure i was
disappointed somewhat
because it's you know not really a great
role model in that sense
i mean now you are of course in some
ways but
um you know it's yeah it was uh i'm sure
i'm sure i probably wasn't happy because
i was kind of led to that
but you know indirectly or directly
right um you know it but but you know
when you have your passion and that was
your passion you found your passion that
young then how can you how can you frown
upon it in that sense i mean yes
obviously the
the standard is to go get your you know
get your high school diploma and
get you know move on to college you know
university whatever
but um if you found your passion that
early yeah you know then you're what
about with your kids you have two
yes boy and a girl yep do you want them
to go to class are they going to college
right now or
already in college yeah um they started
going to
the cool i mean nowadays you can do um
you can do dual enrollment in florida
you can do dual enrollment which is
pretty cool
as of a as a junior you can actually
take
college classes that that um you know
that
you don't have to replicate in high
school which is pretty cool so you can
take
you know your basics um your sciences
and your maths and even economics and so
on and so forth
in call in the community colleges local
and it's pretty cool it's a pretty cool
system um
and yeah so they're my son's in um he's
going um
he's marine biology in ucf right now
university of central florida and my
daughter she
is um this is a pretty cool high school
harmony high school
they have a veterinarian um you can
basically get a certificate
of veterinarian as a high schooler so
you have to do a certain amount of
volunteer hours i think it's like 500
volunteer hours
so yeah they're running the gamut but i
mean this last year has been strange
because they've had to do mostly classes
at home but they're you know they're
rocking it they're killing it they're
doing great
i just want to know a little bit like
like like you worked for him for
what four or five years yep how did why
did you stop working for him did you
fire graham did he do something wrong
no i left him i said later i'm going to
fiji
and you left and you moved the business
to fiji no actually i work i started
work
uh my my business partner for reefer
madness walt smith i started working i
basically started working for him
um and his wife um running the
mariculture
farm uh in fiji
so i that's what i basically ran i i
left
reefer madness um why i never understood
this
because i think when i was like 16 or 17
i just
i never understood like why behind the
scenes or like
why we laughing or like yeah
for some people yes i i got that
question a lot like why would you leave
you're
are you running this company you're
owning this my understanding was that
why would you lose
my rumor or like i guess what my
understanding was that
you got an offer to sell your portion
and that uh it was it was just
such high stress such big hours and it
and it
made sense to take a step back that was
my interpretation i don't think anyone
told me this i think that just went
through my mind
not i mean not really i think it
i'd always had a dream we'd always my
wife and i really had always have a
dream to
to try to do a little bit more
um try to make a little bit bigger
impact and i always thought that
running say like a coral farm um
on the ocean was i mean it was it was i
mean how many people have that
opportunity right
to be able to run a farm a coral farm on
the other side of the world
and living in a completely different you
know uh culture
i mean because as fiji is uh it's
it's a it's completely different it's
not something that you can
you can't take the same things that you
can from here you have to go to like
four or five different grocery stores to
get this the groceries that you would
you know here you go to albertsons or
whatever and you pick up or
you know pick whatever you need up there
you have to go to
you know a meat market you have to go to
a a grocery store
one grocery store to get your milk and
another grocery store to get your butter
and
um and then and then the and then the
farmer's market to get your vegetables
wow um yeah 2007
i think is the last time we've seen each
other so yeah a long time yeah
long time yeah so have you followed like
did you did you find out about a youtube
channel or
we kept in touch briefly about 10 years
ago yeah
a little bit yeah facebook and um
you had mentioned something about
artwork because i was doing some artwork
too when i came back from
fiji i started doing some art and
um you were saying oh yeah you should
post it on reddit and so on and so
forth and i couldn't figure it out okay
um
but yeah um yeah but i i always you know
i followed you your
you know i see your facebook posts about
your hollywood you know all the
the actual properties that you post on
on facebook back in the day and
i'm just like damn this you know he's
got it going on you know yeah
may have flunked but he's you know he's
that classic
you know that yeah school wasn't right
for me but i found my niche
um so yeah um but yeah i always
always followed you and then your
exponential growth now on
on um you know on youtube it's you know
it's it's it's incredible to see
so yeah um but yeah i mean i've always
you know watched from afar and
you know thought it was you know thought
it was um
yeah it was it's you know hats off to
you bro to be able to take whatever
you know those you know what i uh what i
taught you indirectly
or directly in that sense and and um
nurtured your
you know your uh your passion for um
you know for your goal to have a lotus
that was always what you
always remember your goal to have a
lotus that orange lotus that
uh you know that you would you know
dave's uh not they bought one but dave
palmer and
pacific hawk farms um and you'd see it
every day and you're just like
man it's got to be mine yeah and uh so
yeah and
and to see that to be able to take that
um
and uh and and to you know to see what
you've what you've
what you've driven from there is it's
it's it's amazing
um yeah for me it was just the lotus
that's all i wanted yep when i
first saw that lotus and like that was
my only goal it was just i want enough
money to buy a lotus that was it that's
that
that was jack with the tesla jack wanted
the tesla
really badly yeah but
not yet not yet not yet i tell jack my
advice to jack is that as soon as he
gets
the test slots it's immediately it's
going to be something else but it's
really nice to have that carrot
to have that little character for you
was that the same for you
like once you got the lotus you were
just like yeah what's next
yes really yeah what was next
uh yeah
but for a while the lotus was it uh when
i got the lotus i'm like i'm set
that's it don't need anything else as
long as i have the car
i'm chilling um but yeah that lasted
about six months then i was like okay
next is i gotta get a house all right
yeah
well speaking of here i got a speaking
of artwork i got something for you
i don't know if you wanna this is a this
is what i do on my
my spare time when i'm not working it
worldwide corals
i've got i've got something this is uh
this is my other uh this kind of like a
housewarming gift i think here
so this is what i kind of do on the on
my side
[Music]
i took this barn down in tennessee it
was one of my stops
and uh and i
basically carve tropical fish
on my free time and um
this is called a candy basket and uh
it's basically
carved i draw it out i carve it
and then i paint it and it takes me
hours and hours and hours i probably
have a hundred and plus hours in that
piece right there
this i see how detailed it is if you
if you put like uv light on it you'll
see a whole different animal we've got a
different fish
wow it's got pretty cool scales we'll go
we'll get some b-roll of this
wow even though this is out with yeah
look at that
well i mean i've got a i've got a uh a
jigsaw i so so i draw it out by hand i
draw all the
you know fish and then and then make and
then that is
yeah oh cool no this would actually look
really good against the black to find
some spot
part of me wants to put it by the tank
but i feel like it just
it wouldn't it wouldn't stand out enough
up above
yeah okay well we're gonna find
something if you can like hang like a uv
light on it
like a butt like blasted you know you
can see it in front of this one or
whatever but okay
if you can just like a spotlight on it
and it's so cool
so it's you know it's kind of a it's
kind of a cool little
do you sell these i do i do i sell them
i don't
you know i don't i don't make a lot of
them because i i work so much but i
so they're kind of a limited i don't i
will never probably make another one of
these ever okay
of the candy bar wow so it's kind of
it's a limited edition you'll you'll
never see one well you know we'll put
the link in the description
you might sell out pretty quickly how
many are for sale right now there's a
few
there's a few but it's always something
i work you know working for so
there's a link in the description guys
so i have a feeling
you'll you'll sell out of these so the
link in the description you could get
one
they're pretty thank you man so yeah i
love the level of details when you see
this thing
it's nuts yeah from the gill plates to
the yeah that's the thing
yeah like everything is just like looks
like it's a hundred percent
correct piece of you know barn wood wow
of all things it's white oak
so um thank you yeah so yeah so that's
somewhere something you can uh
you know because i see you have some you
have some really cool artwork around
your place so yeah
this i think will go um will go well
with it and mix it well with
it thank you so much yeah very cool
you're gonna see a lot of subscribers
now be like i got one
i got one i know i'm gonna get instagram
pictures look at what i got graham
and yeah like i said i mean i i feel
like i owe like
so much of just what i've learned along
the way to reefer madness and like
having that first
job and just getting the experience of
working at a young age and like being
able to like be surrounded by adults and
see how people work
and like the business behind it even if
i didn't fully understand like what i
was doing or what was involved was so
important for me
so really like sincerely thank you for
that yeah absolutely absolutely and
and the corals part of it you know like
i said i work currently work for
worldwide corals
and it's an it's an amazing place to
work and i mean it's it's spectacular
all the different
corals we have a 1500 gallon reef tank
we have a 1200 gallon lagoon with
mangrove growing out of the back of it
you can look it up on on instagram and
on
uh facebook on youtube yeah um and it's
it's an amazing
um it's an amazing place and you know we
do i run the web department there so all
the corals that you see on the website
it's
very similar to reefer madness and
that's yeah that's cool um the customer
service is
almost exactly i've built it to exact
almost be exactly the same and the care
and the
making sure that we you know produce
products that are true to life and
and growing these corals out and names
and you know everything that we do
i've realized this on my own but i feel
like graham works best if you just leave
him alone
and it seems like you were like you're
pretty like hands-off employer
and i'm not a i am not a micromanager i
never have been i don't like yeah
i don't like being a micromanager i
think that people always second
guess themselves when you're you know
micromanaging so they
they second-guess their own abilities
and i just i can't stand it so i'll give
you a goal
yeah and i'll say you know have at it um
and then i'll give you some little
tweaks on the way
and then um you know then i think that
develops and
and their their the the product that
they produce gets better and better and
better
that's how graham likes to work but see
that's how i like to work but i feel
like
i i do get micromanagey do i
jack i feel like i i do uh a little bit
yeah
you micromanage
you know having you know you've got you
know how many three point one and nine
million point two three point two now
wow
so 3.2 million subscribers you probably
need to more so um but
yeah in the beginning in the beginning
you're very micro managing but now
you've kind of realized that
i i feel like i you've drilled in these
principles into my head so i don't
really
i'm pretty yeah in the beginning it was
deadlines for jack
we we had an agreement that the podcast
would be done 24 hours prior
and then i was sitting there 24 hours
being like it's gonna be soon it's gonna
be
and then like 20 hours i would never
know what's going on i would never
have it it's never gotten done before
and i would be sitting there at midnight
1am
it's not up it's not up we're posting
tomorrow what's going on with this
what's going on
don't worry it'll be up in the morning
first thing in the morning where is it
where is it
no i never missed posting posting i
always had it up
it was always processed it was
everything one time one time with ryan
pineda but that wasn't i had it done on
time
there was just a processing yeah yeah it
was a there's something out like
something like that yeah something weird
so technological
exactly but i had it done on time but i
never missed an upload graham just said
he wants it uploaded an hour before but
i would i'm not gonna lie
i was so busy throughout the week and
it's like to add on the podcast because
i needed that extra day
because that's on a sunday so at least i
could work on it all day saturday and
work on it and stay up late saturday
night
you know but like throughout the week i
had so much stuff i had to do it was
hard to
have this done as well through you know
on by friday
while i have all these other things i'm
trying to do what's your advice for
jack this is great give jack some advice
and jack ask chris for advice okay
chris you could you could you could go
into business coaching after this
business coaching you could seriously if
you
i guarantee if you set up an email
address i'm like i'm half joking but i'm
being serious here
if you set up a business email address
and
i guarantee people would reach out to
you for one-on-one coaching
for business advice because i feel like
you if you have so much that you taught
me
that i would only imagine like what
you've learned along the way
it's possible so if you decide to do
this you have a week to decide
if you see an email in the description
you did it
if not i'm not going to push it i'm not
going to micromanage that but if you
want to do it
if you want to do it maybe i reach out
to you and you can help me with actually
the setup part of it the technological
part of it
maybe i could all it is email email
paypal email paypal
and then and then help people yeah so
people would reach out to you you'll
have a rate
and then people will paypal you in
advance and you
sometimes you just go back and forth
over your email make sure make sure it's
something that you could actually work
with
they'll send you paypal you set up the
time to chat with them well what are you
running into what are your
what are your issues what are you
running into that he has to micromanage
you for
is it still that the hitting the
deadlines or is it different completely
because this is my issues with my job
just in general with with
running this on you
i guess like my only real issues with my
job
is that i wish that i could
do it more like remotely like i because
i i try to visit my family
like at least once every two weeks but
i've been here for it's like i think
like my
my fourth week in a row that i've been
here and i like to spend like a weekend
with my parents
but and also i know that like a few
years down the road
it's going to be really difficult for
for graham and i to be able to do that
kind of stuff
like especially even when i buy a new
house when i buy a house in las vegas
i'm going to want to live there and i'm
going to want to stay there throughout
the day but graham is going to want me
to come here
but most of the work that i do i can do
it remotely grandma think i think just
like
likes my physical presence in the room
if we're like going back and forth on
thumbnails and titles although it may be
the exact same thing if it's over the
air
you know my defense to that is that jack
jack is free to go whenever he wants to
if you want to see your family
uh i'm i'm never holding jack hostage so
anytime
sometimes like weekends like this are
planned out like a week or two in
advance i'm like okay this week we got
this thing planned
next week we also have people flying in
um
but for the most part it's completely
open so just so you know
um no he doesn't hold me hostage i never
hold jack hostage yeah
but uh but now i feel like i've noticed
a difference between
in-person collaborations that you just
can't do
over a zoom call and there's there's
some sort of magic that'll happen if
we're working over a title or a
thumbnail
that and then we we post you know three
three really many times a week
and that's that in-person collaboration
going back and forth and that like
tension in the room of neither of us
could think of a title
uh you don't get the same thing and the
same effect in this over zoom
well i think i think for
for for you you have to have you do have
to have some down do you have any
downtime
yeah i i've definitely like since we
hired alex
like i'm actually working very like i'm
working reasonable hours
you know obviously like i usually start
like later than graham but i usually go
later than graham
like i'll be able to go out play spike
ball with my friends at five come back
at like eight do
you know maybe like an hour or two until
i go to bed so i have like reasonable
hours i can take off time i can come
back
i'm working i'm happy with the amount of
working right now
yeah i mean that's that's one of the
things is that to become a i mean i know
you know for from from all these years
of doing
doing this with the web you know
managing web departments and coming up
with all these you know these names and
i do know that you've got to have a
little bit of down time you got to have
your brain to be able to clear itself to
be able to come up with those
catchphrases you know to come up with
those names for you know
so that they're exciting that they can
click you know for a click on so i do
know that you know managing your time
wisely and allowing yourself to you know
to clear that
to clear your brain is is important but
um
you know for the deadlines to be able to
work for i mean if you guys have a
specific goal that you need
that you you know that you're trying to
get to um
you should probably need to you probably
need to buckle down and just you know
and deal with it for a little bit longer
until you get to the point where
you can make that decision between the
two of you guys rather than
you know i also think one other thing i
think graham needs to instill a little
bit more trust in me
because you mean like i did with him
back in the day yeah like he'll
he'll if i if i want to make a decision
do you have i mean are those
does he have the fortitude to be able to
you know to to be able to do that i feel
like like we're in therapy right now
like we're a mediator here uh yes
so like like obviously things that
benefit graham benefit me
and i totally see that and i recognize
it and
and for certain things like like i was
picking out a new router
for the house right like for for the
wi-fi because we drastically needed it
and i spent a lot of time alex spent a
lot of time he researched it
it was such a pain in the butt calling
the wi-fi company trying to figure out
what's wrong with it
i sunk so many hours trying to figure
out the new router and then finally
out you know alex too we settled on a
router that we liked and like these
satellites that we liked with the router
and i go to best buy and then graham and
i had like some back and forth on like
the cost of the router
and i thought it was i don't remember it
i thought we did it
no you're speaking about it with costs
exactly come on but the thing is it's
like it's for the business
and not only is it for the business but
like you're going to have me a full-time
employee
and alex a full-time employee and graham
and macy and everyone's going to be
hogging up all the bandwidth on the
and it's just very important that we
have fast wi-fi and graham was like i
hope you don't spend more than this
amount
and i'm like dude if only you realize
how important it is to have wi-fi that
doesn't cut out
we would literally be sitting right here
trying to get to comments or like be
posting a video
and the wi-fi would like not work we
would have to move to another room
it was so dumb we moved to another room
because the wi-fi wasn't working here
but when we were other
when we were in the other room this is
still graham you're speaking of yes so
you know we all know oh just wait we
know we were in the other room the video
wasn't performing and graham said
it's because we're in this room so we
came back here and the wi-fi wasn't even
working
i'm superstitious i have to be sitting
right superstitious or super
super yeah stupid stitches stupid
i have to be sitting right there when i
post a video otherwise it doesn't
perform well
we've tested other locations the wi-fi
wasn't even working here but they don't
but okay here's the ques you upgraded it
yeah i upgraded the wi-fi
now you
yeah okay yeah but there was flak from
graham and it's stuff like that where
it's like obviously
what i want is going to be what is best
for what is you know for graham and what
is best for graham is what is best for
me so
so here's the thing i he has to heed my
my requests and advice uh i i got the
fastest internet that you could buy
with with this thing and it was just
this location here so i think
my rebuttal there was let's call up the
wi-fi company and see if they'll fix it
you don't know how many hours i spent
online with cox it was because i was
like
my thing it was like okay we're paying
for the good one we should get that
service
it's worth it so you're saying the trust
factors and the trust after all these
years of working together and there's no
trust factor
yeah it sounds like 95 the quality
if i was working elsewhere that's okay
so here here's a point
right we talked about earlier about um
you know some of the things that you
learned at reefer madness as well um
sometimes if you have something say you
know
shipping out around coral or customers
not happy with something so on and so
forth
it there it's seeing kind of play with
sometimes
improving upon something to improve
something else
is hard to see when you're already in it
and you're focused on this particular
thing should work
but yet there's an alternative to be
able to surpass that
and go beyond that because we all know
that cable companies
are not always the easiest to deal with
yeah so um finding a separate route
i mean maybe i don't know i'm just
saying that that maybe in the future you
have other
technology uh technological advances
that you need to make in the uh
in around the house like uh we do so we
do
so maybe maybe you need to do the same
sort of thing you can say okay well
this is the drawback and here is the
benefit
you know we could save even if it's one
hour a week to get an imac
that's worth it and the quality will go
away i said we could get an imac and
we're gonna go once you test it out
though the happy
a happy employee is a good employee yeah
i figured
i did i mean i work with both but you
know i dig
them they never fail you yeah they never
fail they never lock up they never i
mean
it's it's it's unbelievable how
efficient they are
so that we could get one and i just i
just how many do you
do you need more than one yes i just
wanted to point out
that we we they don't fail you they
don't
we have i'm so i don't know i know
you're editing different
stuff that i didn't i i'm still using
the same yeah i get it
how many was it how many youtube
subscribers three two two
okay and it's like four between all
yeah i saw some of the number you make
per hour oh yeah yeah
so you me in one hour would basically
save
a lot of money yeah okay yeah yeah but
and then you pay for i don't like to
make big changes i like that you know
everything's the same we'll do it slowly
we don't need to go all crazy with two
imacs well get one i give it to alex
have alex deal with it a little bit
i'm splitting the cost so whatever
whatever graham and i buy for alex that
means i'm in fifty percent i'm totally
cool with that
you know oh yes so there you go
but i need one two you're paying for one
yeah he's paying for one wants to wait
for me to wait what do you want
generation two or something
no he just wants how long i don't know
he just and there's there's no it's like
my advice if you really think it's gonna
make that much of a difference
do it and you know what i just want to
say i talked to anes
after because we we recorded a podcast
with someone right before you came here
and he has like he has a youtube channel
with these crazy like cameras and
equipment and all this stuff 100 grand
in equipment for filming and i talked to
him afterwards he pulled me aside and he
says
you know what man like i didn't want to
say this on the podcast but you were
right
you you guys got to upgrade your
equipment like it makes sense
he said he says i admire you know graham
wanting to sell you
to you know use the towels as light
diffusers and stuff like that like i
admire that
but at a certain point it only makes
sense to to scale up because
think about where you'll be three years
from now are you still gonna use the
towel as a light diffuser
are you still going to use the canon 80d
yes okay what about 10 years from now
maybe if it would work but i think it
just makes sense to to scale up and to
build remember how excited he was about
that
the the sony yeah right yeah the sony
my camera all of my equipment it was
like three thousand dollars
and i i spent three thousand dollars and
graham is rocking with like a a six
hundred dollar
camera works it works it does that's
what it's like
why fix what isn't broken it's been
working this entire
experience i think for the viewers to
have a like
it just is i mean the only the only
thing that i always see is that and i i
sometimes do this too
and graham's behalf is that if it does
work
you can see all your upgrades but the
problem is a lot of times the upgrades
are
is that unless you have somebody that
isn't comfortable to make that upgrade
you always fall back to what works so
making that upgrade
sometimes doesn't fulfill your need nor
does it
nor does the cost basically make it
make it an advantage for you if you
can't if you can't make it work
so that's always the thing you have to
look at is that are you going to use
that upgrade are you going to be able to
use those
particular things that are going to make
that you know make that upgrade
i wouldn't but you know what because
you're here
jack we'll get two macbooks we'll get
we'll do it
we'll do it just because chris is here
and just because we're talking about it
i will make the leap of faith we're
gonna get to you could order them right
after this
but make sure to keep the costs yeah
we're going to get the decked out ones
down okay maybe wait for a sale
is there a memorial wait wait wait wait
wait wait wait wait wait let's have an
apple you just said
yeah make the purchase after this you
know after the podcast but now you're
saying wait for this
change no i'm thinking now that's no
problem you're thinking
sale that's true alex has an apple card
you get five percent
five percent off okay see i'm excited
now you need to pay me
there you go i'm very excited even
though i'm dropping probably like two
grand i'm very excited
very excited and alex is getting
in the background over in the corner
yeah you can see his computer too
if you could go anywhere in the world
where would you go because you've done a
lot of traveling right oh can i answer
this question too
uh no where would you go jack
uh thailand why thailand
because it's cheap and the culture is
beautiful it's it's a beach town but
it's also very green
you know um it's beautiful the culture's
cool jack actually had a trip scheduled
to thailand
and then the illness hit yeah and then
it was the first time out of the country
yeah yeah where would i go
i mean it's always been a dream that
like i think i mentioned to you earlier
to dive with those
the white humpbacks in the northern
islands of tonga
that that would be that would be
something else or with the mayonnaise
there's a few locations where you can
die with mana rays i've done it once a
dovan with
amana mana ray once in the middle of
nowhere actually christina and i just
this captain we were with he's like we
thought it was a plastic bag in the
ocean it was
and he's like no that's a mana red jump
in now and we just got
through on our mass and just in the
middle of nowhere in the middle of the
ocean like you can't
like you can see islands you know but
they're you know probably a mile away
and we just jumped in and sure enough
here's this manta ray just feeding he's
just doing these
loops and we're you know chugging them
after you're chugging
you know flying swimming as fast as we
could behind them watching this manta
ray just do these loops and just
eating the plankton and that was
incredible so
to see something like that or to even
you know to dive with the with white
humpbacks that is
that would be pretty the south the
humpbacks of the south pacific they're
they're basically their whole most of
their body like three quarters of their
bodies just
white and it's just incredible why
haven't you done that yet
work just working so much you know me i
mean i just i just work i just
do a lot of work if i'm not working
worldwide worldwide
i'm working on my art and you know or
usually it's like
one day of art and you know doing
artwork and then
the second day is a family day so you
know where we spend one of those days um
being a family and doing stuff as a
family so um
yeah for the most part yeah is it
possible to get time off like how long
would you need
um to make that trip yeah
you probably need a good um
10 days probably 10 10 days or something
how long is that to travel it's it's a
haul
no tongue is not quite as far um fiji's
11
11 hour 10 and 11 hour flight tongas
depends i think you can go through
hawaii you can go hawaii and then down
to tonga i believe
there might be some straight shots out
of la um but yeah coming from like going
from florida
over yeah it's it's it'd probably be a
good 12
12 to 13 hour flights yeah cool well i
would like to do that
for you and christine whoa so you
literally let me know when we'll make it
happen okay dang
all right you're gonna come on are you
gonna come with me maybe we'll see
if you come with me yeah if you i don't
know if i can get the time off
you you're going to if i can make it you
can make it then i can show you then i
can show you what
why why i move to the islands of fiji
then you can then you can see
why you know well then if i go then jack
and alex
have to go to go to yeah i mean we could
make it
assumed yeah you can yeah we could make
it a you know that would be
pretty pretty crazy that would make
sense
incredible float footage wouldn't it
we just got to get christine away from
you know um slowly get her
away from being camera shy right yes
okay
realistically do you know when you would
be able to get 10. i don't even know if
i don't even it'd probably have to be
probably if we could do it but probably
next year i would have to go
okay let's let's aim for that then yeah
because i think
you know with the corona and all this
stuff still shut down but
um yeah it should open up i don't know
it should open but but then
all right yeah yeah we'll yeah we'll
make it do it
yeah but that would be a lot of fun that
would be my gift to
thank you for everything that you've
done for me and i think that would be a
fun experience that would be
that would be fun yeah yeah well perfect
for sure there we go
going to tonga
and now you're going to tango look up is
pretty cool this is a great episode this
is a testimonial
for uh for you as a business coach you
should be doing the same thing too
because you got
jack a macbook or what is it an imac
computer
and a trip and alex is obviously gonna
come along so we could vlog it
uh you should do the business consulting
i would do 175 an hour okay that's what
you should be doing all right that's
what you actually do
nice yeah 175 an hour yeah
do that for 45 minutes would i actually
do it yeah
sure okay i'll do it if the email is in
the description you did it if not then
no worries i don't want to press it but
sure but yeah you
i think that's great that's great jack
will testify it worked for him
it worked for me yeah it's got it cost
me money so
uh so there you go jack all right is
there anything else
i don't think so just really
appreciative that you came on the
podcast very nice to meet you
yeah absolutely it's been like uh yeah
absolutely it's been a long time
um but it's yeah this is this is a lot
of fun i mean this just happened
just hit me up a week you know a week
ago and and uh christina
like yeah let's let's make it let's make
it happen yeah it's just it's an
adventure i love adventure yeah
i love adventures like i said totally
last minute things like how is this
weekend
sure let's do it do it yep i mean it was
cool it was fantastic of you to be able
to
work as a you know work us into your
you know crazy busy schedule so we did
it yeah you did it
cool been a lot but yeah thank you so
much for coming on yeah thank you thank
you for everything my pleasure
it was a lot of fun it's cool this is
this is a this is a really good
experience it's it's it's it's fun it's
loose it's not
you know and i think that's that that
bodes well to
bringing out the the personalities of of
the true personalities of people that
you have
you have on your show which is awesome
it's not it's not uh
you know it's it's not in a situation
where you feel like you have to
you know be outside of yourself exactly
which is very cool
and i appreciate that thank you guys
you're welcome thanks so much and thanks
so much for the fish
so with that said you guys thank you so
much for watching i really appreciate it
uh we're gonna link to your information
down below in the description but
before you leave make sure to subscribe
hit the notification bell
hit the uh subscribe button and also you
can get your free stock worth all the
way up to 70
down below in the description when you
sign up for public you know how much
seventy dollars
seventy used to be fifty it's going up
no it's seventy dollars for a limited
time
and you could potentially get a
completely free stock of tesla
so if you want that down below in the
description use code gram
that's it it's pretty much like free
money so enjoy thank you guys so much
for watching and until next time
okay make sure to hold the mic this way
all right yeah there you go
all right